[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen Wintersport und mehr
hat Rudi zerne für Sie in gut 15 Minuten
schönen guten Abend das sind die großen
Themen
heute Kampf gegen die Überschwemmungen
in Nord und Ost bleibt das Hochwasser
gefährlich in Niedersachsen muss ein
Tierpark evakuiert werden
die Silvesternacht im Blick während
Polizei und Feuerwehr vor erneuter
Gewalt warnen startet der bundesweite
böllerverkauf und bereit für die
verchanzentournee bei der Qualifikation
in Oberstdorf zeigen sich die deutschen
Skispringer in
Topform es sind weiterhin viele Menschen
im Norden und Osten Deutschlands von
Überschwemmungen betroffen allein in
Niedersachsen sind mehr als 100000
Helferinen und Helfer im Einsatz gegen
das Hochwasser Feuerwehren berichten
jetzt dass sie dabei beleidigt werden es
viele Schaulustige gebe und Sandsäcke
die an Deichen verbaut sind von
Anwohnern weggeholt werden um ihre
Häuser zu schützen über die
Hochwasserlage Thomas
gonsor Wasser überall in Winsen nördlich
von Hannover die aller fließt eigentlich
um Teile der Gemeinde herum nun durch
sie hindurch Hochwasser bis zur Haustür
mindestens
in der Siedlung westuh verlassen auch
heute die Menschen ihr Zuhause das geht
nur noch mit dem Boot viele haben bis
zuletzt
ausgehart heute Nacht ist das Wasser
aber immer wieder weiter angestiegen und
jetzt ist mein Freund hier mit dem Boot
gerade unterwegs und holt die letzten
Sachen und hat noch alles versucht
irgendwie zu retten was zu retten geht
raus aus dem Flutgebiet heißt es dort
für 300 Menschen schon vergangene Nacht
Bürger auf der Baggerschaufel Anwohner
auf dem Traktoranhänger für alle gab es
Notunterkünfte ganz ähnlich die Lage
weiter nordwestlich zwischen Oldenburg
und Bremen Weser wörpe Wümme laufen über
Flussgebiete als
Seenlandschaft betroffen ist hier etwa
Liliental und teils evakuiert 5000
Sandsäcke konnten einen deichriss nicht
verhindern immerhin den Rettungskräften
gelang es bisher die Fluten etwas
einzudämmen jetzt richtet sich unsere
Sorge allerdings zunehmend darauf dass
die Deiche auch tatsächlich weiter
durchhalten und deswegen wird überall
gerade geschaut gibt es
Nachbesserungsbedarf nachbessern
vorsorgen auch in Sachsen Anhalt damit
die Wassermassen Magdeburg keine
Probleme bereiten fließt ein Drittel des
elbwassers nun durch einen umflutkanal
und aufs offene Land dafür öffnete das
präziner weer erstmals seit einem
Jahrzehnt seine schweren Eisen das
entlastet den Fluss kündlich um
abertausende Liter überhaupt Entlastung
gab's heute vieler Orts dort wo der
Regen nach Tagen
ausblieb und wir haben es gehört einer
der Schwerpunkte der Hochwasser ist
Niedersachsen dort liegt bei Hannover 60
km nördlich der seringeti Park
Hodenhagen auf dem 220 Hektar großen
Gelände Leben 1500
Wildtiere nun sind weite Teile des
Areals überflutet
Tiere mussten in Sicherheit gebracht
werden Klem Altmann
berichtet 20 000 Sandsäcke verbaut und
trotzdem ist der Serengeti Park in
großen Teilen überschwemmt mehr als 1500
Tiere sind von den Wassermassen
umschlossen 1974 wurde der Park
gegründet Probleme mit Hochwasser hat es
nie gegeben jetzt sind rund ein Drittel
der Fläche mit Wasser überflutet größtes
Problem die Wärmeversorgung einige
trfationen wurden überflutet kein Strom
auf dem gesamten Gelände unsere
Techniker sind ohne Ende am arbeiten
dass wir Stromkreise in in Gang setzen
können um eben für tropische Tiere oder
warmliebende Tiere eben die Heizungen
und vor allen Dingen die
Wasserversorgung auch zu gewährleisten
für die Tiere aus den Tropen ist es zu
kalt ihre Stelle müssen evakuiert werden
unter anderem die Unterkünfte der 20000
Affen doch das klappt nicht mit allen
Tieren die Giraffen werden wir wohl
nicht rauskriegen die stellen wir
trocken versuchen die auch leer zu
pumpen der Schaden ist immens aber auch
die Hilfsbereitschaft selbst aus anderen
Teilen Deutschlands gestern stand hier
100 Leute aus dem
ahal von irgend so ein kleinen vin die
wollten helfen die hatten futtermöhren
mit in Kisten experten rechnen damit
dass es wegen der angekündigten
Regenfälle noch 10 Tage dauern wird bis
das Wasser
zurückgeht Baldes Silvester i und
Feuerwehr rechnen erneut mit
Ausschreitungen im vergangenen Jahr
wurden ja im Einsatz und Rettungskräfte
in verschiedenen Städten etwa im Raum
Stuttgart in Bochum und Berlin
angegriffen in der Hauptstadt kommen
jetzt per Video eindringliche Worte von
Einsatzkräften Ksten beren
berichtet das Video ein Appell an den
gesunden
Menschenverstand greift uns nicht an
schießt uns nicht mit Böllern Raketen
oder Schreckschusswaffen ihr macht euch
strafbar und euch drohen mehrere Jahre
Gefängnis mit dabei Feuerwehrmann Baris
schoban er wurde Silvester 22
angegriffen und ist auch dieses Jahr
wieder im Einsatz wir müssen irgendwie
versuchen den Menschen da draußen mehr
zu zeigen Mensch da steckt auch ein
Mensch hinter dieser Uniform der auch
eine Familie vielleicht zu Hause hat und
einfach nur seinen Job versehen möchte
Silvester
2022 hatten überwiegend jugendliche
Täter Einsatzkräfte angegriffen und in
Hinterhalte gelockt das soll sich nicht
wiederholen vier Böller Verbot gibt es
in diesem Jahr unter anderem rund um die
Sonnenallee in Neuköln wo es im Vorjahr
besonders heftig
zuging ich habe ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen Angst weil ich vermute dass es
genau wieder so laufen wird wie im
letzten Jahr auch wenn Böller Verbot ist
ich meine jeder kann ja Spaß haben und
knallen aber bisschen brutsamer die
Sache im Gaza wenn man das zusammenhängt
dann wird glaube ich schlimmer hier die
Furcht der Krieg in Nahost könnte die
Stimmung bei arabischstämmigen Berlinern
zus anheizen Berlins Polizei geht mit
einem rekordaugebot von insgesamt 4000
Beamten in die
Silvesternacht wir werden mit B Camps
ausgestattet sein und last but not least
kann es auch sein dass Wasserwerfer zum
Einsatz kommen die auch im letzten Jahr
einerseits gelöscht haben die wir aber
tatsächlich auch so stationiert haben
dass sie zum Einsatz kommen könnten die
Hoffnung es soll ein friedlicher
Jahreswechsel werden in Berlin und
überall
und seit heute darf offiziell
Silvesterfeuerwerk verkauft werden die
Branche rechnet mit einer hohen
Nachfrage
Umweltschutzorganisation Ärztinnen und
Ärzte und die Gewerkschaft der Polizei
fordern dagegen ein
böllerverbot jedes Jahr werden Menschen
durch Feuerwerk verletzt teilweise sogar
schwer vor allem illegales Feuerwerk ist
gefährlich mehr dazu von Stefan
Kelch Finger weg sonst Finger weg eine
Kampagne der Bundespolizei in Zittau an
der Grenze zu Polen denn verbotenes
Feuerwerk kommt meist aus Polen oder
Tschechien Kontrolle klar aber vor allem
Aufklärung was in Deutschland erlaubt
ist was verboten ist was auch die
Gefahren darstellt es gibt leider jedes
Jahr zahlreiche Verletzungen
geschmuckelt wird das ganze Jahr in
einem Kleintransporter fand die Polizei
illegale Böller mit insgesamt 32 kg
Sprengstoff das kann Gefängnis nachs
sich ziehen die Entsorgung muss der
schmuckler auf alle Fälle bezahlen 500 €
Minimum und was das ist der Albtraum der
Ermittler eine Kugelbombe die explodiert
im Bruchteil von einer Sekunde ja das
ist wahnsinnig gefährlich wer sowas in
den Händen hält immer wieder explodieren
zu Silvester auch illegale Böller sie
verletzen sehr oft Jugendliche deshalb
geht die Bundespolizei in der
Oberlausitz an Schulen der Schock
heiligt die Mittel ich W's
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr machen damit
muss man glaube ich rechnen wenn man
sich solche Böller holt dass es
vielleicht zu sol Ausnahmen kommen
könnte heute früh in Dresden
Verkaufsstart für die Enthusiasten des
wirklich gepflegten Feuerwerks muss es
definitiv legal sein lieber das
legale Feuerwerk weiter erlauben lassen
und dadurch kommen halt auch
logischerweise weniger illegale
Feuerwerkskörper nach Deutschland der
Trend geht weg vom simplen Knall nur 4%
der legal verkauften Feuerwerkskörper
sind Böller und die haben eine CE
Kennzeichnung darauf zu achten kann
Finger und Leben retten
die gescheiterte pkwmaut bleibt für
csuptiker andreas Scheuer juristisch
ohne Folgen das
Bundesverkehrsministerium verzichtet
darauf den früheren Ressortchef auf
Schadenersatz zu verklagen laut einem
Gutachten geb es ein erhebliches
Prozessrisiko sowie Zweifel ob Ansprüche
durchsetzbar seien für dieeplatzte
pkwmaut muss der Bund den beteiligten
Firmen 243 Millionen Euro Schadenersatz
zahlen
Menschen die Bürgergeld beziehen und
sich immer wieder weigern einen
zumutbaren Job anzunehmen müssen mit
schärferen Sanktionen rechnen so steht
es in einem Gesetzentwurf von
Arbeitsminister Heil das Bürgergeld kann
demnach für maximal zi Monate komplett
gestrichen werden die Kosten für
Unterkunft und Heizung werden
weitergezahlt aktuell dürfen Jobcenter
maximal 30% des Bürgergelds
Kürzen der Tod eines Generals der
iranischen Revolutionsgarde Anfang der
Woche hat den Konflikt zwischen Iran und
Israel verschärft heute bei der
Trauerfeier in teeran skandierten
tausende regierungsanhänger Tod für
Israel und Tod für Amerika General
musawi war bei einem Luftangriff in
Syrien getötet worden Iran macht Israel
dafür verantwortlich israel hat sich
dazu nicht
geäußert in die Ukraine wo der Krieg
längst zum Leben gehört vor allem im
Osten des Landes besonders schwierig ist
es für Schwangere denn Angst und Stress
können zu Frühgeburten führen es gibt im
Ukrainisch kontrollierten Teil des
donbas nur noch eine Säuglingsstation
die Frühchen versorgen kann und zwar in
pkrowsk nur etwa 40 km entfernt von der
Front Alisa jung war dort das ist Dascha
sie ist 36 Tage alt doch sie sollte noch
gar nicht auf der Welt sein dascha ist
ein Frühchen wurde geboren im donbas im
Osten der Ukraine hier gibt es nur ein
Krankenhaus in pokrowsk das Babys wie
Dascha helfen kann trotz der
Raketenangriffe arbeiten Sie hier weiter
wir mussten uns beruhigen die Situation
akzeptieren und wieder arbeiten um den
Frauen zu helfen seit Beginn der
russischen Invasion gibt es immer mehr
Frühchen rund 10% mehr als vor dem Krieg
schätzt das
Krankenhaus wenn Sie eine Explosion oder
ein lautes Geräusch hören bekommen die
Frauen natürlich Angst und werden in
einem Stresszustand hier eingeliefert
dann ist es logisch die Frau ist
gestresst und bekommt
Schmerzen die Frühchen im Inkubator
brauchen Ruhe Wärme und Dunkelheit ihr
Start ins Leben kostet schon so viel
Kraft wenn hier der raketenalarm ertönt
bleibt den Frauen nur Schutz auf dem
Flur zu suchen weg von den
Fenstern wir brauchen zumindest zwei
Wände nach außen denn wir können nicht
alle sozusagen unter diee
unten in den
bukerenen diese Babys wurden geboren im
Krieg wie Varvara D Tage alt ihre Mutter
nadja ist trotzdem voller Glück und
Zuversicht alle hier in der Region sind
sehr besorgt aber das Leben muss
weitergehen sie sagt aus großer Liebe
werden glückliche Kinder
geboren wie könnte es 2024 mit dem Krieg
in der Ukraine weitergehen dazu gleich
ein ZDF heute live mit exnatokommandeur
Rams um 19:30 in unserer
App vor genau 10 Jahren begann China
seine strenge eInk kindindpolitik zu
lockern denn durch den Geburtenrückgang
droht die Gesellschaft zu überaltern das
bedeutet dass es zu wenig junge Menschen
gibt die die älteren versorgen können
obwohl jetzt wieder mehrere Kinder
erlaubt sind entscheiden sich viele
chinesische pa
dagegen wurden in den 70er Jahren
statistisch noch über sech Kinder pro
Frau geboren werden es 2023 geschätzt
nur 1,2 sein zum Vergleich in
Deutschland sind es knapp 1,5 aus Peking
berichtet Elisabeth
Schmidt so wie Chun denken heute viele
Frauen in China auf keinen Fall ein
zweites
Kind eines genügt ich habe nicht genug
Energie für zwei meine Eltern sind alt
und ich muss mich um sie kümmern sie
wollen auch ein gutes Leben haben oft
reichen die Renten nicht aus zum Leben
deshalb müssen viele Familien die
Großeltern finanziell unterstützen hinzu
kommt teurer Nachhilfe Musik oder
Tanzunterricht für die Kinder in China
gang und gebe die Weichen für eine gute
Karriere sollen möglichst früh gestellt
werden doch in Zeiten der
Wirtschaftskrise wird das immer
schwieriger in großen Städten wie Peking
haben sich die Immobilienpreise in den
vergangenen Jahren mehr als verdoppelt
viele junge Mens sind arbeitslos
Kindergeld vom Staat wie in Deutschland
gibt es nicht die Lebenshaltungskosten
für ein Kind sind einfach zu
hoch ich will keine Kinder das würde
viel kosten mit dem Geld könnte ich
reisen China drohen über Alterung und
Fachkräfte Mangel die Regierung unter
Druck die ein kindpitik war ganz
offensichtlich ein Fehler dieinesische
regiersingend ein groesderprm für
familiengenorte Entlastungen bei
Wohnungen und
Häusern doch statt mehr Entlastung für
Familien ordnet statschef C eine neue
Ehe und gebärkultur an die gebotenzahlen
sollten steigen und Frauen sich auf
traditionelle Werte besinnen Chinas
Sozialpolitik macht eine Rolle rückwärts
und setzt Chinas junge Leute noch mehr
unter
Druck wie gewinnt man dringend benötigte
Fachkräfte das fragen sich überall in
Deutschland viele
Unternehmen setzt man jetzt auf eine
Jobbörse an einem ungewöhnlichen Ort den
Weihnachtsmarkt dort werben jetzt Firmen
für sich und versuchen auch weggezogen
auf Heimatbesuch zur Rückkehr zu bewegen
Franziska
wunderlich noch immer weihnachtet es in
Kemnitz doch neben Glühwein und
Pfefferkuchen gibt es in den letzten
Tagen des Jahres nun auch Jobangebote
unter der Pyramide hier zwischen den
Jahren in so einer entspannten Stimmung
ist es schon ein unterschied sich mal
unverbindlich zu informieren da hat man
kein Druck man muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt so performen wie im
Bewerbungsgespräch ein Dutzend
Unternehmen aus der Region werben für
sich und um gut ausgebildetes Personal
wir haben am Standort in Südwestsachsen
etwa 800 Mitarbeiter ein gutes Dutzend
an Stellen sind immer frei und jede
nicht besetzte Stelle minimiert
natürlich den Umsatz in Sachsen sind
knapp 40.000 Stellen unbesetzt
demografischer Wandel und Abwanderung
sind Gründe dafür nun geht es darum die
die einst weggingen mit guten
Jobangeboten wieder nach Hause
zurückzuholen für unseren Sohn wir sind
schon zurückgekommen vor 4 Jahren und
wir hoffen dass er auch zurückkommt die
Aktion finde ich grundsätzlich schön
weil es Publikum anspricht welches man
normalerweise nicht erreichen würde noch
bis zum 30.12 läuft die Aktion und
könnte für manchen ein neuer Start im
neuen Jahr
sein die skisprungfans fiebern der
vierchancenournee entgegen und seit
heute ist ja die Jagd auf die
siegtrophäe eröffnet R genau auf den
goldenen Adler den du gestern schon
gesehen hast und die Deutschen sind in
blendender Verfassung bei der
Qualifikation fürs erste Springen in
Obersdorf schafften es fünf Deutsche
unter die ersten 12 am eindrucksvollsten
unterstrich Andreas wellingersande
Ambitionen auf den turnesik der mit 135
m den besten Sprung schaffte für mehr
Begeisterung hätten die deutschen
Springer vor Rekordkulisse in Obersdorf
nicht sorgen können Karl Geiger und
Andreas Wellinger ganz v
deutlich vor dem Weltcup führenden
Österreicher Stefan kraft dessen in
diesem Winter härtester Rivale Wellinger
sichert sich mit diesem marellosen
Sprung auf 135 m hauchdünn vor Geiger
Rang 1 das ITüpfelchen auf seine guten
Trainingssprünge da bin ich mal extrem
happy jetzt mit dem Tag weil einfach der
Prozess und die drei Sprünge von der
Qualität saark war und das ist für die
nchsten Tage auf und
aufen to Ergebnis
ab cypria Sarasin gewann überraschend
die Weltcup Abfahrt in bormeo in Italien
der 29-Jährige feierte seinen ersten
Weltcupsieg in der Königsdisziplin auf
der 3,6 km langen eisigen Rüttelpiste
fuhr Saras ein couragiertes Rennen und
lag im Ziel knapp vor dem Schweizer
Doppelweltmeister Marco odermat als
bester Deutscher erreichte andreas
Sander aus Ennepetal Platz
19 und bei der darz WM in London ist der
vierte von fünf deutschen Profis
ausgeschieden der Kölner Florian Hempel
unterlag mit Favorit Steven bnting mit 0
Z4 und verpasste damit den Einzug ins
Achtelfinale Florian Hempel startet
famos beendet früh eine Runde mit zwei
dreifach 19 gefolgt von einem Treffer
ins Bulls ey 164 Punkte der Wahlkölner
wirft im ersten Satz einen
herausragenden Punkteschnitt von 107
doch Gegner Steven Banting trifft noch
besser im Schnitt 105 Punkte der
Engländer holt sich so den ersten Satz
in der Folge Banting immer ein Tick
präsenter konstanter übers gesamte Match
im Schnitt 101 Punkte Weltklasse Hempel
verliert trotz guter Leistung 0 Z nach
Sätzen Banting bekommt es im
Achtelfinale mit Michael van gen zu
tun präzise Würfe die Jana bewundert ich
war beindruckt wirklich danke Rudi
wechselhaft mit Regen und Sonne geht es
morgen weiter Details dazu gleich von
östtin terle Christian siers begrüßt sie
um 21:45 Uhr zum heutejournal und morgen
übernimmt hier Barbara hallweg auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter es bleibt
ja bei dieser westlichen Strömung
dementsprechend kommt auch weiterer
Regen mit dazu auch relativ milde Luft
also von Schnee ist erst einmal keine
Spur und wir sehen hier den Regen in
blauen Flächen eingetragen in unsere
Karte und das sieht in der Nacht
folgendermaßen aus im Nordwesten kommt
Regen auf hier sind auch einige Gewitter
dabei nach Nordwesten ist der Wind auch
kräftig teils stürmisch im Süden gibt es
einzelne Schauer bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von Werten bis zu 9° ganz
im Westen relativ mild z.B 5° nach Osten
hin ja und morgen dann im Tagesverlauf
kommt die Front weiter Richtung Mitte
voran und es regnet aber wie gesagt es
sind nicht die großen Mengen im Süden
gibt's auch Sonnenschein an der Nordsee
weiterhin stürmisch und das bei höchsten
Temperaturen von 7° hier Richtung
vogland und 13° im Südwesten die
kommenden Tage am Samstag einige Schauer
aber auch hin und wieer der Sonnenschein
6 bis 12° Silvester gibt's weiteren
Regen und Sturm an der Nordsee schönen
Abend